Russian President Vladimir Putin has
accused NATO of being an indirect
accomplice to crimes committed by Kiev
he also accused Western powers of
working to disintegrate and control
Russia on the ground the moscow-backed
Wagner group says its Fighters have
captured the village of yagonoye north
of bakmut fighting has been concentrated
around the city for weeks let's get more
on the view from Moscow we can speak to
Osama bin Javed who is in the Russian
capital for us Osama Putin leveling new
criticism in NATO this is the first time
we've heard from the Russian president
isn't it since Western allies hit Moscow
with new sanctions
well yes obviously this is the latest
round of sanctions which came into
effect yesterday 87 in entities 43
individuals who've now all been named in
this latest round of EU sanctions where
it seems to be now honing in on the
individuals and entities which have been
able to help Russia circumvent all of
these previous sanctions 11 000 in total
in the last one year that have been
applied to Russia so President Vladimir
Putin obviously wants to come out and
tell his people and the outside world as
well that this is an existential battle
for Russia it is continuing its fight
against what he calls a an alliance
which wants to defeat Russia and
interestingly enough after his State of
the Union Address where he did mention
uh Russia suspending the new Star treaty
with America again he's talked about
nuclear capabilities of not just the
United States but all the Western Powers
which Russia says it is fighting against
because it sees Ukraine as a proxy me of
the West not just Ukrainian forces
and what are you hearing about the
fighting that is continuing on the front
lines around bakmut in eastern Ukraine
well in the last few months you've seen
that Russia has concentrated reinforcing
its positions and the Wagner contractor
group seen as mercenaries by Ukraine and
its allies have been able to inch by
inch take more territory uh especially
in the donesque region uh the city of
bahrwood remains the flash point for the
last few months where there's been
dogged fighting between the two groups
uh both sides entrenched trying to make
sure that they have the upper hand but
in the last few days we've seen these
statements from the Wagner group that
they've been able to take Villages from
the south they've been able to advance
from the north yesterday we heard from
the Russian Ministry of Defense sources
saying that they're investigating
Ukrainian forces blowing up a dam to
slow down their advances in the city of
bahmud it remains a flash point but it
is not a strategic City it is more of a
city which is going to give them a Depot
a movement sort of a position which is
going to be symbolic rather than
strategic but this fight remains on the
Eastern parts of Ukraine where majority
of the people are Russian speakers and
that has been used as a pretext to the
war by Russia saying that it is fighting
for those people who want to be part of
Russia no longer Ukraine